you know what's coming up if you go to
play arena tournaments you have to
change the link to
calendar this is coming up the spring
marathon
very soon we might have a
at least a 12-hour livestream
i don't know if i'll ever get around to
playing a whole 24-hour
marathon so anyway i'm gonna join
i'm probably gonna join the spring
marathon yeah let's join it now
but i'm not gonna play at this stream
because
i'll have to still wait two days maybe
i could turn into ludwig and just stream
non-stop until then but
let's um play a tournament that's going
on right now
yeah hourly rapid we're gonna have some
slower more chill constructive chess
thank you shaking ponds
lucid alder binge watching videos
recently nice
oh binge watching my videos even nicer
oh i just said i said we're gonna have
slow oops
that was more reflexive like i saw the
rating i clicked the bun
okay we're gonna have maybe one stafford
gambit hopefully
please take here and then take here
okay we'll have a four knights it can
still be fun
um yeah so bishop b5 is probably one of
the
main moves it's better than bishop c4
bishop c4 there is uh the center fork
trick
so okay so white concedes the bishop
pair
immediately and then goes wins my pawn
um i know there's a reason this isn't
good for white but
i'm gonna have to figure it out if i
play queen d4 and that goes back to f3
i can't easily win the pawn um
so the move is probably queen e7
provoking d4 and then taking them
and what we do to people during rabbit
season
rabbits oh do we do we feed the rabbit
the wabbits carrots remind me later
or do we hunt the rabbits
yeah so white has a lot of targets in
the position d4 is um
probably one of the better moves but now
there's pressure
attacking the knight twice the knight's
pinned
i can draw arrows also i'm threatening
f6
to potentially remove the light and then
some discovery so castling is actually
very logical
d as in d file um
i think i'll win a pawn
question do i take with knight or bishop
i mean we trade rook has to move here
and then i castle rookie one
i think i kind of got away with just
like winning the pawn and
not suffered too many consequences
yeah i kind of i reached into the cookie
jar
i grabbed a cookie and i'm getting away
with it
white's a little bit more developed
it's going to be slightly annoying to
[Music]
bring this bishop into play because it's
kind of tied down
so what i might end up doing oh okay
that probably helps me
i was gonna say that maybe i'll play
this and this
um but trading
trading looks reasonable
it's still a question how i develop the
bishop
okay i have an idea i'm gonna trade and
then play
f6 man because always play f6
and the point is i want to play b6 but i
don't want to lose c6
so after knight moves i'll play b6 and
then
i don't know if my vision wants to be
here here but i'll have some choices
mouse pad only asking what flavor did i
get
wait what flavor what
can anyone guess what i'm drinking by
the way i'm drinking something i don't
usually drink
a very exotic drink
first person to guess correctly gets
gifted a sub
let's see how i give this person a sub
i've never gifted someone to sub to my
own channel
i know this is going to work i feel like
i'm just
paying twitch with this
this work
hey i'm a sub gifter to my own channel
good job camster3211
who said water i'm drinking water look
at this
it's kind of hard to see but it's uh
it's h2o
i've seen other streamers do it
occasionally
um so i'm pretty sure it's allowed
i'm sure twitch is okay with it
um i have to figure out how this will
work on my taxes
yeah i'm drinking water i took a long
walk earlier today
um
[Music]
and i walked like over eight miles today
according to my apple watch i'll play a5
just uh creating happy pawn structure
don't think light realize my queen helps
support c4
oh i forgot to do a walking
i stream people were requesting it my uh
because i took a walk yesterday too
maybe tomorrow but tomorrow i'm
collabing with levy i'm trying to walk
more
next walk maybe i'll i'll go live and
just experiment
see if it actually works
but it's been warmer here so i'm trying
to
regulate my body temperature i walk to a
nice kind of nature place nearby
hello hello madd2488
actually i got i got chased by uh
i think it was a goose duck or a goose
i took a picture let me see if i can
find it
there is like a really photogenic there
were i think two geese and
two ducks
yeah i can show the picture maybe after
this game
[Music]
it didn't hiss it just started sprinting
towards me
also g5 double x
g5 it looks like a fork but white
counters with a pin
a pin is mightier than the fork
so maybe i'll be tricky i'll just play
king h8
be very sneaky hunting some rabbits
i hope my phone's not watching i
revealed my whole
i know that five's a natural move anyway
revealed my whole evil plan please go
back to h4
how many pawns i'm up i'm up two pawns
i won yeah the pawn on c3 and then the
pawn on c4
i have to be a little bit careful here
it's like weird
coordination for white everything's
still defended
queen is very clutch on g7
[Music]
i i was still threatening g5 there to
win material but
now white's being slippery with a knight
um now f6 is kind of undefended if i
play this white gets an outpost
i could play this but i can see the
fight for the file
[Music]
oh there's a tricky there's a tricky
line also i'm low on time
so the tricky line is i allow white to
take on f6 and then i pin
and hopefully win
for a moment so sexy i got kind of
scared
but now i'm also kind of flattered thank
you medusa blah
for a moment i thought rookie 7 was
hurtful because if takes
and white mates me but thankfully
um actually rookie 7 if i take the
knight i still get
mated so here thankfully i have this
move
everything should be okay
that's kind of tricky line for both
sides
yeah sometimes you have to be careful
like when you provoke the opponent to
to go in like sometimes it can backfire
but okay
oh rookie seven wow okay so thankfully
everything is under oh no
i think i did actually blunder
i'm gonna stop talking
maybe i should have played maybe h5 was
just a bad move
oh no
i know things are okay okay so the the
rook the
queen and the pawn are hanging by this
move
why only has one check i think
one reasonable check and king g8 and i'm
carding these squares i'm threatening
the f pawn bishop
is in the center
i do have to watch time as well
okay i got a little bit uh complacent
there
focused too much on things that weren't
relevant to the position
i'll still have to show the goose the
goose photo
i was gonna take video but um i
felt in danger okay so now i can take
that's funny we're both trying to attack
on the king side
light has a classic seventh ranked
battery
but i think my attack will be more
successful
something made in two
i think white's best move is queen h2
it's like interesting defensive idea
because then if i take the rook then
check and etc
i was trying to bait my opponent but uh
okay
uh so white has the seventh rank
um the seventh rank
goodness but i have a windmill i have
made in one
okay all right yeah queen h2 was
it was not my proudest like anti-stream
smite move
anyway thanks for the game proficia
yeah it got weird
um i mean
i think all all of the plays should have
been
objectively good maybe not the most
practical but
let's check real quick
um okay so h5 is the top move
king h8 okay king h8 is um
yeah this is all i think this is all
fine
yeah i kind of had to walk a thin line
there
i just got here have we talked about the
hikaru drama yet
uh no i don't really know enough to
comment so
um but you're you're just in time for me
to talk about what happened earlier
so i took a walk i saw these
um i mean it was like a nice kind of
photo scene
the the ducks were sandwiched between
what you
these are geese right are they just
larger ducks
i mean this looks like a duck also
there's some cool symmetry with the
reflection
but is this a goose i don't know
people are saying duck one person says
quack
okay so i i came up and
then i got a little bit too close i was
trying to get like the
better resolution um so
they started like swimming towards me
and
i assumed they wanted food i didn't have
any food
and this guy was particularly
i guess provoked and he got out
and then this is the last photo i took
before i started running
because it started just sprinting after
me
i was terrified i was like clearly
in a threatening pose so the other ones
were just kind of chilling
but this one it had a beef
with me i don't know what i would have
done if it started flying towards me
thankfully like i sprinted away like i
was faster than it
and it just it stopped chasing me but
um if it started flying towards me
whoa it's fifty dollars that's awesome
let's go thanks splendor prone
if it started flying towards me i
probably would have just tried to
duck